Your brain is lying to you right now.
Not in a small way, in a fundamental
life destroying way you can't even see.
Watch this mental trick. When you buy a
specific car, suddenly you see it
everywhere. Those cars were always
there. The paradox, the smarter you
think you are, the better you get at
finding evidence to support your biases.
Here's what separates the truly
intelligent. They actively search for
information that proves them wrong. The
less you know about something, the more
confident you feel about it. It's the
Dunning Krueger effect. Real
intelligence sounds like doubt. Think
about this mathematically. Improve by 1%
daily, you're 37 times better in a year.
Decline by 1% daily, you lose 97% of
your value. The question is, will you
act on what you now know? Because
knowing without doing is just another
cognitive bias.